[Applaudissements]
corruption trafic d'influencé des six y
ont truqué par des réseaux d'influencé
obscures qui passe entre washington
bruxelles paris si vous regardez un peu
dans la presse
c'est un peu les messages que vous allez
recevoir sur la pratique de mon métier
en fait en gros nous reproche de
favoriser des intérêts particuliers au
détriment de l'intérêt général
voire même de s'asseoir complètement
ceux d orge et économique et financier
notre pays
et puis ensuite il ya les affaires alors
à bruxelles il ya eu il ya toujours la
faire du lobby du tabac à paris je vais
penser par exemple à cash investigations
qui dénonce dans l'agriculture l'usagé
des pesticides
et puis par exemple points voilà je vais
vous pouvez en trouver
pléthore puisse confiant en général
quand on parle de mon métier on va
d'abord se référencer à ce type de deux
messages
alors quand vous allez dîner avec des
amis pour rencontrer des gens très
sympas on discute avec vous que vous
d'un moment vous dis mais alors tu fais
quoi
et là je préfère avec médecins ce que
c'est un peu plus cool du monde a des
petits bobos agents immobiliers on a
tous besoin d'un toit au dessus de la
tête lors quand vous dites que vous êtes
le beast en général sa glace un peu et
pourtant je suis le bij depuis presque
vingt ans j'ai travaillé à bruxelles
pendant très longtemps en tant que
fonctionnaire français pour défendre des
intérêts à bruxelles
ensuite j'y suis revenu venus travailler
à paris j'ai travaillé aussi dans
plusieurs pays européens
je défends désormais des intérêts de
grosses multinationales américaines on
en a parlé tout à l'heure
maintenant suisse et puis je me regarde
de temps en temps dans la glace quand
même je me dis waouh corruption
conflit d'intérêts ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est ma pratique je vous avoue que
je me retrouve pas vraiment là dedans
alors le lobbying c'est quoi ces
méchants c'est gentil c'est compliqué et
ça vient d'où vous expliquer en fait ce
que je fais et comment ça se passe le
lobbying en fait c'est en vous trouverez
plein de définition la commission
européenne dans des textes de loi la
mienne en fait je suis le porte-parole
celle qui va défendre des intérêts une
position devant des décideurs politiques
je vais essayer de leur expliquer que
sur telle et telle réglementation par
rapport à l'entreprise ou les intérêts
que je représente je pense que c'est
plus ou moins positive plus ou moins
négatifs pourquoi je vais pas forcément
en tant que le bis représenté uniquement
des intérêts économiques de
multinationales je peux aussi travaillé
pour des tpe/pme c'était mon cas
auparavant
vous pouvez aussi trouver des lobbystes
dans des fédérations professionnelles
dans des syndicats mais également dans
des associations de consommateurs je
pense par exemple à que choisir qui
avait pris une position à l'assemblée
nationale il ya une dizaine d'années où
il revendiquait être des lobbystes sas
et je trouvais ça très très fort et est
très moderne et vous pouvez aussi
trouver des lobis alors on va les
appeler autrement va appeler ça du
plaidoyer dans des ong dans des
associations de patients
on a tous le même métier on a fait la
même formation
et puis on peut passer de l'un à l'autre
ce métier dont je les dis c'est la
défense en fait d'un intérêt particulier
spécifique
l'association un problème de droits des
consommateurs de l'environnement du
digital à un instant t et donc on
représente on appelle des parties
prenantes une expression de la société
civile pour essayer d'expliquer les
vertus ou pas de telle et telle
réflexion
et tout ça en fait part dans de
l'angleterre la définition des parties
prenantes du lobby c'est en angleterre
en fait lobby veut dire couloir et le
lobbyiste c'est celui qui était dans la
chambre des communes à londres qui
essayer d'interpeller les parlementaires
avant qu'il ne rentre dans l'hémicycle
pour adopter une décision pour les
convaincre que tel et tel intérêt était
important ou telle et telle décision
parce qu en angleterre en fait tu le
sais très liés à l'industrialisation
donc début du 19ème et c'est le souci en
fait de se dire que lorsque vous
représenter un intérêt particulier vous
voulez en fait améliorer quelque chose
pour votre votre propre compte
si c'est positif sans le savoir vous
risquez d'apporter une valeur ajoutée à
la société donc si on fait une
caricature la somme des intérêts
particuliers va définir l'intérêt
général alors qu'en france on a une
conception politique complètement à
l'opposé de cette tradition politique
anglaise on retrouve aussi aux états
unis en france on va faire beaucoup plus
référence au contrat social de rousseau
où on va dire en fait que le peuple
détient à l'intérêt général et que quand
ils votent et qu'il nomme un élu il lui
donne en fait ce pouvoir de savoir ce
qui est bon pour le peuple et sa forge
en fait toute une tradition politique à
bruxelles vous allez être entre deux
c'est-à-dire à bruxelles vous allez
avoir des institutions qui sur le papier
semble fonctionner à la française on
retrouve des cabinets ministériels et
structure très pyramidale
mais leur fonctionnement est beaucoup
plus anglo-saxon puisqu'en fait
bruxelles pour pouvoir savoir ce qui est
bon pour la population est là entre elle
et la population des états qui souvent
défendre leurs propres intérêts
économiques des régions et aux fines et
comment est ce qu'elle fait pour savoir
ce qu attend des acteurs économiques et
des consommateurs et donc elle développe
un système de concertation et c'est à ce
moment là que les lobbystes s'exprime
c'est à ce moment là on pense que sur ce
sujet là
d'aller dans telle sens que dans tel
autre mais qu'en est il de la france
donc à bruxelles à washington que la
première place de lobbying au niveau
mondial on va estimer à 30000 lobbystes
à bruxelles on estime entre eux ou à peu
près 20 milles le beast en france on ne
sait pas il n'y a pas vraiment de
chiffres établis
alors je me suis un peu renseigné et on
va estimer si on est dans un ordre de
grandeur qui a à peu près 4000 structure
en france qui vont défendre un moment
donné ou à un autre leur intérêt auprès
des décideurs politiques qui vont faire
un autre gros mots de l' influence
alors je me rappelle en fait à titre
d'anecdote inde un appel un jour d'une
journaliste américaine qui me dit je
vois que vous estimez être lobbystes que
vous le revendiquez
mais en fait il ya quelques ce que je
comprends pas il ya le faisait référence
et j'aimerais vous m'expliquer elle
faisait référence en fait à la sphère
des éthylotests en 2012 où le
gouvernement fillon a décidé qu'en fait
chaque automobiliste devait avoir un
éthylotest de façon obligatoire dans sa
boîte à gants
l'idée était plutôt positif c'est à dire
l'idée c'était de réduire les accidents
de voiture du fait de la consommation
d'alcool et de demander aux conducteurs
de lui-même d'avoir un éthylotest
c'était une façon de le responsabiliser
sur sa consommation d'alcool et surtout
de réduire la dépense pour l'état c'est
à dire les quand vous êtes interpellé on
ne sait pas l'état qui paye éthylotests
mais le conducteur
en fait le problème c'est que la
présidente de la fédération des
accidents routiers a fait la une des
journaux en disant que cette décision
était scandaleuse parce qu'elle avait
favorisé une entreprise française dont
le carnet de commandes explosait et donc
elle sous-entendait qu'il y avait
conflit d'intérêts encore ce fameux mot
je vais pas rentrer dans le détail de
savoir si c'est vrai ou si c'est faux ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'en fait
quand elle a appelé les élus pour savoir
qui elles avec avec qu'il avait discuté
elle a découvert qu'en fait un salarié
de cette entreprise
était président de la fédération des
éthylotests en france et que c'est lui
qui avait su donner cette idée et elle
me dit quand j'appelle un parlementaire
et que je lui dis est ce que vous avez
reçu ce monsieur a oui absolument
et alors qu'est ce que ce le vis de vous
a dit ah non moi madame je ne discute
pas avec les lobis moi je les sors à
coups de pieds au cul de mon bureau et a
dit mme emmanuelle j'ai discuté avec qui
vaste question alors bien entendu la
discute avec un lobbyisme je vous ai dit
qu'ils avaient des leviers dans les
fédérations professionnelles et c est en
fait ce qui est intéressant c'est que la
question du terme le bing est en soi
sulfureux donc il ya une association en
france qui s'est penché sur la question
et s'est dit alors l'association qui
regroupe des lobbystes de d'entreprises
françaises
si on peut pas s'appeler lobbies comment
on peut s'appeler c'est après tout c'est
peut-être une sorte de mot on a cherché
on a fait des études marketing d'état
denquête on a regardé dans les
différents pays où la pratique est
courante et puis en fait je pense moi
personnellement que peu importe on peut
s'appeler directeur des affaires
publiques 17 directeur des affaires
institutionnelles ou le beast un chat
est un chat le sujet pour moi il n'est
pas dans la dénomination il est dans
notre pratique et c'est une un sujet sur
lequel j'ai commencé à me pencher quand
je travaillais à bruxelles puisque donc
on a une définition et un encadrement
qui a été posée dès 1996 à bruxelles et
à une accélération en 2004 puisqu'il ya
un commissaire européen qui s'appelle
sim kallas qui a décidé de de s'emparer
du sujet et de poser une réglementation
est un cadre un petit peu plus strictes
et c'est là que j'ai décidé moi de créer
mon association qui s'appelle base qui a
plus de dix ans qui compte plus d'une
centaine de le beast en france pour se
dire non à bruxelles il ya des
réflexions il ya un cadre en france
qu'est-ce qui a pas grand chose on en
parlait déjà pas beaucoup ou quand on en
parle c'est plutôt un mal
je me suis dit qu'est ce que je peux
faire pour que ce sujet on s'en emparer
que ce soit reconnue comme une activité
comme une autre et qu'est-ce que je peux
faire pour que le comportement peu long
à dans un cas
professionnels restent respectueux d'un
certain nombre de règles en france le
sujet est arrivé beaucoup plus tard je
dirai après beaucoup de colloque etc et
d'avoir travaillé avec d'autres
associations
c'est monsieur sirugue à l'époque
parlementaire aujourd'hui secrétaire
d'état qui en partie repris les
fonctions de monsieur vaqueront qui
s'est emparée du sujet en 2012
l'éthylotest et décide en fait de
reconnaître la valeur ajoutée du lobby
en disant voilà les lobbystes apporte
une expertise à un instant t une analyse
d'un texte il défend une position mais
pour ça on doit savoir qu'il est quel
intérêt il représente quel budget ils à
quels sont les dossiers sur lesquels il
va travailler dans un registre on porte
un badge et on sait à qui on a affaire
cette réglementation a évolué puisque on
a un texte de loi qui a été adopté il ya
deux trois semaines qu'on appelle dans
notre jargon le texte sa part 2 qui dont
vous avez certainement entendu pas dans
la presse qui pose en fait la question
de la protection des lanceurs d'alerté
et et temps la réflexion à la
reconnaissance des des lobbystes en
france alors on n'appelle pas ça le bing
représentants d'intérêts l'errance cette
déclaration obligatoire intègre les
cabinets ministériels certaines
administrations certains élus locaux et
donc aujourd'hui on a un cadre légal qui
est fixée en france on devra tous
respectés et qui j'espère démystifiera
un peu cette pratique
après si je fais un petit peu un retour
sur moi pour continuer de vous casser
les idées préconçues
je ne suis pas la femme d'un homme
politique je ne suis pas la fille d'un
homme politique et je ne fais pas de
politique
j'ai des convictions personnelles en
tant que citoyen je vais voter mais je
je ne suis pas encarté ou proche d'un
parti quelconque je ne vis pas sur un
carnet d'adressés je ne passe pas ma vie
en cocktail petit forcément je serai pas
là ce soir
je travaille j'ai un métier avec des
techniques de travail on a d'ailleurs à
base publier un ouvrage on essaye de les
expliquer de les présenter
il ya un an et demi et puis ensuite je
pense que toujours dans cette réflexion
d'un débat démocratique moderne on doit
être capable d'exprimer des intérêts je
pense que chacun doit rester à sa place
le lobbyiste présente une analyse
explique clairement qu' il est pourquoi
il est là quels sont les enjeux qu
est-ce qui pense qui est positif au
négatif en fonction des intérêts qu'ils
représentent et l'élu lui il écoute mais
il écoute tout le monde il va écouter
l'ensemble des parties prenantes je vous
en ai donné un certain nombre il
réfléchit il forge son opinion et
ensuite ils décident ce qu'ils pensent
être bon pour la collectivité
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]